this is Winnie the Pooh teaches me how
to be a better person and to really not
stress out about life this right here
hey you Oh bother
[Music]
hey what is going on u-tube now this is
a video topic that everybody wanted me
to get into but I couldn't because I was
out in vacation which is why I look like
a roasted pork right now
they call me lechon so don't forget to
have this sauce with the vinegar with it
if college don't work for you RJ you can
potluck and dance your way to a future
well guys this video has been circling
circling you idiot that's not a word
guys this video has been circulating
around the internet and a comedian named
Shane Gillis was cancelled and removed
from SNL because he used a racial slur
specifically against my peoples full
[ __ ] China I wonder how that started
they just built one [ __ ] up looking
building and people were like alright no
one said anything chinks live there well
they built these [ __ ] like huge
Shanghai out the first one was
infuriated every window I know the man
casually just slipped in this word [ __ ]
and they were having this whole diatribe
and conversation about you know Chinese
food is dishonesty what they thought
about Chinese all this other stuff and
that and you know I think people have
been asking me what do I think about
number one what they were talking about
and number two
should they be cancelled okay well let's
talk about cancel culture for a second
because number one I'm not too hot on
cancel culture because I feel like
specifically when it comes to creating
content a lot of people are just looking
to take down somebody for anything that
they said in the past and specifically
when it comes to humor a lot of that
stuff can get misconstrued now having
said that watching this video clip I
don't think there's anything to be
misconstrued the way he casually just
used the word [ __ ] is probably where
people really got pissed off because his
stance on this after he put out a public
statement was he's a comedian that likes
to take risks and if anybody was
offended by this he's sorry number one
that's not really apology number two
what the [ __ ] do you mean risk the
problem is for me anyways the risk that
you thought you were taking it wasn't
really a risk it was just you used the
word [ __ ] because for some [ __ ]
reason and I believe that a lot of Asian
people can agree with this is that when
it comes to Asian racial slurs people
think that it's nothing like you could
just say it however the [ __ ] you want
but you say that you're a comedian that
likes to push boundaries right but what
[ __ ] boundary were you pushing
where's the punch line is what I'm
saying as a comment to another comment
where is the [ __ ] punch line my guy
that was the problem that people had
there was no punch line you said the
word so [ __ ] casually and you said it
like it was [ __ ] nothing I'll give
you a great [ __ ] example by the way
just so people don't think I'm the
hypocrite Dave Chappelle on this last
special did a racist Asian Joe he goes
hey guys I dream it was the most
old-fashioned way to do a racist Asian
joke but the punchline wasn't about
Asian people he was talking about how
ridiculous something can be right so
there's a punch line to that joke
whether I was offended by that joke or
not I understood the joke the setup in
the punch line and to me that's why it
was funny
there was no setup or [ __ ] jokes of
what boundary are you pushing so what
you're saying really doesn't [ __ ]
make sense neuters I hate you I hate the
food of Chinese now sucks
Chinese foods are very dishonest cuisine
I don't think they invented a [ __ ]
chemical to put in their food to make it
delicious dude they made us a msg it's a
dishonest food dude there's nothing
there's nothing to it it's a shitty
shitty meat a chemical they made up to
[ __ ] your body up and noodles neuters he
said Chinese food is the most dishonest
food out there might be a little - how
far you can first of all you're a
[ __ ] white boy you don't ever get to
talk about the conversation when it
comes to food and flavor [ __ ] your
people just figured out what salt is you
want to talk about dishonest [ __ ]
food you see you eat hot dogs shut the
[ __ ] up
Asian people ain't this honest with the
food we just [ __ ] eat everything what
are you talking about I don't know how
you say Chinese food is dishonest when
you're the one who's [ __ ] eating at
the most you little [ __ ] boy just to
show you how
you really don't know about food and
this is the reason why your combi is not
funny MSG is not a made-up [ __ ]
chemical it's a naturally occurring
thing you [ __ ] [ __ ] and on top of
that to Emma she isn't bad for you so
suck my [ __ ] nuts it was a podcast it
was regular conversation not to say that
podcast can't have comedy and there
aren't jokes in it but the way that you
were talking about the whole new ders
thing which by the way old [ __ ] joke
and number two my god dude it sound like
you were disgusted with like Chinese
culture get the [ __ ] out here with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] how you gonna talk [ __ ] about
Asian people when you dress like you
work at one of our factories you Panda
Express eating [ __ ] boy Asian food is so
[ __ ] good you're still not done
appropriating you're talking about dis
honest food [ __ ] you eat saltine
crackers and Lunchables for lunch like
that's a [ __ ] meal get the [ __ ] out
of here looking like you just escaped
Michael Jackson's basement you McAuley
[ __ ] boy [ __ ] yeah and it's it's full
[ __ ] Chinese in there is that kind of
like nice though
isn't that being level people go into
legal Mexican restaurant like I'll to
tacos imma bowl of spicy neuters in the
translation between you and and I know
you can say this to your Chinese people
make fun of Chinese people all the time
everybody knows this [ __ ] we can joke
about these inside stuff because it's
inside jokes it's personal to us people
understand where it comes from that's
why it's funny you're an outsider
staying an outside perspective on stuff
that you don't [ __ ] know about are you
gonna talk about other people's cultures
in the way they [ __ ] conduct
themselves when you look like you [ __ ]
your stepmom looking like you work for
Asian people you [ __ ] low ladder step
boy shut the [ __ ] up if you don't like
the food don't go to the spots then ah
me go back to your cache we'll go back
to your broccoli and cheese and then
boil your chicken breasts with I don't
know but mrs. - you [ __ ] bland [ __ ]
but just to go back to him talking about
comedy and pushing boundaries and then
he's a comic he's very funny if you were
really pushing boundaries and you wanted
to use a racial slur I would really
really really really love for you to use
the n-word in that same statement with
the hard arm here's the thing I wouldn't
bet my [ __ ] money on it that you
would have never ever said that on your
podcast you know why because you
understand how harmful and hateful that
[ __ ] word is you understand the type
of public backlash you would get from
using that word but because it's Asian
people using the word
even though it's a racial slur Asian
people aren't gonna say or do anything
about it and you were [ __ ] wrong you
were dead [ __ ] wrong you were dead
Korea wrong and that's that's kind of
what Asian people have to deal with a
lot right is that we get pushed to the
side when people say these racial slurs
they kind of say oh it's not as bad as
saying it is it it totally [ __ ] is
looking like you three years old and
forty at the same time bitch-ass
[ __ ] whether he kept his job on
SNL or not I really don't care it
doesn't it doesn't really matter as a
comic people say offensive [ __ ] all the
time and they still get to perform so if
he's a great comedian he's [ __ ] funny
whether he's on SNL or not his fan of
comedy career should still skyrocket and
still should do well right that's my
thoughts on that [ __ ] talking about
Chinese food and neuters you stupid [ __ ]
okay talk about msg it's not called msg
dude it's just called seasoning stupid
bland [ __ ] see you guys next time hey
what is going on YouTube I hope you
enjoyed that video right off the [ __ ]
cuff unwritten just straight to the
point if you guys want me to do more
videos like this write in the comments
below stay interact like and thumbs up
and share this video because it's
culturally important [ __ ] but as
you guys know I do have a patreon on it
and you could tell I cut some storm so
this video probably not gonna make much
money at all but if you want to continue
watching these videos and you want me to
continue to make this stuff I have a
patreon that you guys can donate to if
you like it if you can't just come back
to this channel and like it share and I
gotta say guys patreon content is up
yeah baby came out and he fed all the
fish in the ocean but because of this
man we got to see a cute little turtle
it's crazy this one right here is not
going into the water because she's so
good she's no they're always acting like
she's super tough but now she's just